what's going on guys this is rob and
welcome back to another installment of
10 minute expert on geek culture
explained and in this video we're
continuing our coverage of mortal kombat
as we approach the release of the new
film and today we're focusing on mortal
kombat's coolest character
sub-zero get it
but anyway there have actually been two
different characters that have operated
under the sub-zero mantle within the
mortal kombat universe and the first of
these characters is bihan who is the
sub-zero that we see in the original
mortal kombat game in 1992. now be han
is a member of the lin kuei an ancient
chinese clan of warriors and we get a
glimpse into his origin in mortal kombat
mythology sub-zero which was a terrible
game
[Applause]
[Music]
which sees sub-zero hired by a demonic
sorcerer named quanchi to steal a map
from a shaolin temple now during his
quest
sub-zero encounters scorpion a member of
a rival clan known as the shirai ryu who
had also been hired by quan chi
to get the map now the two of them fight
sub-zero kill scorpion and then brings
the map back to quan chi
who rewards him by wiping out the
entirety of the shirai ryu clan now quan
chi then sends sub-zero on another
mission to retrieve an amulet that had
been protected by the deities of wind
fire water and earth but sub-zero
defeats them and quan chi
takes the amulet which is actually the
power source for shinnok the elder god
and then disappears into the nether
realm now raiden another elder god
makes sub-zero follow quan chi into the
nether realm to get the amulet and when
he does he's once again tasked with
fighting scorpion who's under the
employee of quan chi now sub-zero
defeats scorpion retrieves the amulet
and then returns to raiden the lin kuei
then gives sub-zero his next mission to
compete in the mortal kombat tournament
and kill the sorcerer
shang tsung now following the tournament
bihan is murdered by scorpion and two
pretty significant things happened the
first is that quan chi
took his soul and turned him into an
undead entity known as noob saibot who
would appear in later installments of
the game the second is that b
han's younger brother takes up the
mantle of sub-zero and would appear as
sub-zero in all of the mortal kombat
sequels now like his brother
huay liang was a member of the lin kuei
clan their father had been living in
america as a spy for the lin kuei and
was descended from a race of cryomancers
magicians with the ability to control
ice and so he takes his sons back to
china and then trains them both to be
assassins for the lin kuei clan now upon
adopting the sub-zero code name kwai
liang vows to finish what his brother
had tried and failed to do
kills shang tsung but he runs into
trouble in the form of a perpetual thorn
in the lin quay side
scorpion now scorpion initially believes
that sub-zero is behind back from the
dead but then realizes that it's not
actually him when he shows mercy to an
opponent and upon learning his true
identity
scorpion vows to be sub-zero's protector
now sub-zero later tries to leave the
lin kuei tribe along with his friend
smoke as they've become disgusted with
the clan's new practice of turning their
members into cyborgs unfortunately
smokes kidnapped and converted into a
cyborg along with two other lin kuei
warriors
cyrax and sector and the three of them
were tasked with hunting sub-zero down
now sub-zero joins raiden's efforts to
protect earth realm from the resurrected
shinnok
and once again finds himself on the
wrong side of scorpion who's yet again
been tricked by quan chi into blaming
sub-zero for his family's death like my
god you'd think scorpion would have
figured it out by now like hey maybe
this guy's just constantly duping me but
in 2002's mortal kombat deadly alliance
we saw a sub-zero challenge sector for
the leadership of the lin quay and
sub-zero wins and then takes on an
apprentice named
frost who would then challenge him to
become the leader of the clan but
sub-zero would defeat her as well now
overall this new sub-zero proves to be a
much more honorable version of the
character than his older brother had
been
frequently outlying himself with the
defenders of earth realm like raiden and
liu kang
against threats like shinnok the elder
god and the dragon king onaka who were
determined to see the realm destroyed
now he has an extremely
strong sense of honor and even after
encountering and defeating his older
brother noob saibot he remains dedicated
to seeing his brother restored to his
former self and now
we reach the point where the mortal
kombat timeline reboots completely with
the release of the 2011 game
simply titled mortal kombat so this
version of sub-zero's story once again
starts with bihan
and he's killed by scorpion and is still
turned into new cybot and just like in
the original timeline
his brother steps up to assume the
mantle of sub-zero to honor his older
brother's death and that's when things
get different in this timeline the lin
kuei are once again turning their
warriors into cyborgs but instead of
smoke getting cyberized like the
original version this time
it's sub-zero that's transformed against
his will and forced to serve xiao kang
the emperor of outworld now sub-zero is
able to overcome this transformation
however and takes up
arms against shao khan alongside raiden
and his forces
he battles and defeats his older brother
but is killed by sindel the wife of xiao
khan and is then revived in the nether
realm as a revenant by quan chi
i gotta be honest guys this dude just
keeps showing up and messing stuff up
for sub-zero and scorpion but anyway we
learned that both of the sub-zero
brothers were actually abducted by the
lin kuei
as babies and that the clan had
essentially killed their parents now
after quan chi resurrects him sub-zero
is forced to serve in his army but
raiden is able to break the hold quan
she has over sub-zero sub-zero then
capitalizes on the opportunity of
finally being in his right mind and
physical body to reform the lin-quay
over the next couple of decades
but first he has to get control of the
clan away from sector and so mortal
kombat 11 the latest installment of the
series
introduced a new villain in the form of
chronica a titan who can control time
now she uses her power to bring sector
from the past to the present and then
aids him in converting
all of the linquay to cyborgs in order
to serve in her army now sub-zero
recruits scorpion to help him infiltrate
the linquin's headquarters and the two
of them basically become besties and
manage to defeat frost noob cybot and
sector and then shut the facility down
and so sub-zero fights with raiden's
forces to defeat kronika and then the
game simply ends and after the ending of
the game we get a character-specific
ending for sub-zero and that he has an
hourglass that he wants to use to reform
the lin kuei but realizes that in order
to do that he has to figure out why his
brother bihan was so easily corrupted by
sector and quan chi and so when he does
he reforms the timeline so that the
original sub-zero
never goes bad and the two brothers rule
the linque as co-grand masters so they
both get a happy ending and that's the
story of sub-zero in the mortal kombat
franchise which is a bit convoluted to
say the least but what's made sub-zero
such a popular character is because he
looks
awesome and has cool powers so i wanted
to explain what his powers and abilities
are now as i said earlier he's descended
from a line of cryomancers so he has the
ability to manipulate ice by changing
the temperature of any water around him
including the water in the bloodstream
of his opponents now both versions of
sub-zero are said to be able to achieve
temperatures
of negative 500 degrees fahrenheit which
is colder than absolute zero so that's
theoretically impossible but it also
kind of makes sense because his name is
sub-zero not absolute zero although i
feel like absolute zero would be an
amazing name for a character in mortal
kombat but sub-zero is also an expert
hand-to-hand combatant and also uses his
powers to make weapons out of ice that
he uses in battle now in mortal kombat x
sub-zero comes into possession of an
artifact called the dragon medallion
which makes his ice powers even stronger
and also gives him
greater control over his cheat which
makes his melee attacks
more damaging as well and yeah that's
basically all you need to know about
sub-zero probably one of the more
interesting characters in mortal kombat
in terms of backstory but i hope you
guys enjoyed this thank you all for
watching and we will catch you guys
later
peace